[موسيقى]
vmx هي رياضة سريعة الخطى من
وقت سقوط البوابة وحتى عبور
خط النهاية ، فأنت دائمًا ما تفكر في
حركتك التالية طالما يمكنني الاحتفاظ
بهاتين العجلتين على الأرض
سأكون كذلك  هناك على هذا المسار
[الموسيقى] ،
اسمي كيتي ويست ساعة وأنا أبلغ من
العمر 70 عامًا ، أنا أكبر متسابقة BMX
في الولايات المتحدة
شاركت في رياضة سباقات BMX
كمتسابق منذ ثلاثين عامًا حتى الآن و  أحب
التحديات وكان هذا مجرد
تحدٍ آخر عندما بدأت سباقات البي إم إكس ،
لم يكن هناك فئة طراد للسيدات
عملت مع هيئات العقوبات لدينا
وتحدثت عن حقيقة أن النساء يرغبن في
أن يكن جزءًا من هذا ،
لدينا الآن الآلاف من النساء والفتيات
اللائي يتسابقين  في جميع أنحاء البلاد
[موسيقى]
نذهب هناك 56 وأكثر من النساء 70 عامًا
الآن تجلس الآنسة كيتي ويسترن في
هذا السباق ، حيث يوجد الكثير من النقاط الإجمالية
طوال كل عام سأفعلها في أي مكان
من 25 إلى 30 سباقًا وغالبًا ما
أتسابق كثيرًا  الشابات
انتهيت من حد ذاتها  الخامسة في العالم في
فئة 45 وما فوق الطراد للسيدات ،
كنت أكبر امرأة تشارك في
عالم UCI BMX ، وهذا أمر لا يصدق ،
ويمكن أن تكون هذه رياضة خطيرة في عام 1993
، حيث تعرضت لحادث حيث
كسرت دراجتي بعد السقوط من دراجتي  قيل لي عن رقبتي
أنني قد لا أتمكن من
المشي مرة أخرى ولكن في غضون ستة أشهر
عدت إلى السباق
واستمررت في الانخراط في الروح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هاها ، شكرًا لك ، حقًا ، أنت
تعرف أن الناس لديهم  سألتني عن المدة التي
أخطط فيها لمواصلة سباقات دراجات BMX ، فأقول
للناس أن العمر ليس سوى رقم
وأعني بجدية أنه في كل مرة أخرج فيها
على هذا المسار أفوز ولا يتعلق الأمر
بعبور الثانية أو الثالثة ولكن الأمر
يتعلق بالمتعة  يتعلق الأمر
بالاستمتاع بالوجود مع الآخرين الذين
يستمتعون حقًا بهذه الرياضة ، وأريد
الاستمرار في الاستمتاع
بالحياة وهذا جزء من حياتي
[الموسيقى]